veamos si podemos resolver un par más de
ejercicios de identificación de cónicas
tengo el siguiente problema tenemos
x cuadrada
más que cuadrada
- 2 x + 4
igual a 4
entonces lo primero que me gustaría
hacer es descubrir de qué tipo de cónica
estamos hablando aquí tengo mi término
de x cuadrada y mi término de cuadrada
ambos están del mismo lado de la
ecuación y ambos tienen coeficientes
positivos así que esto me dice que
estamos tratando con una elipse y en
este caso en particular los coeficientes
son iguales ambos son 1 y con esto
sabemos que es una circunferencia
ahora pongamos esto en su forma más
simple y tratemos de graficar la
circunferencia primero queremos
completar el binomio al cuadrado
perfecto así que tenemos nuestros
términos de x que son x cuadrada menos 2
x más algo para completar el cuadrado
más adelante
y ahora hagámoslo con los términos de y
de cuadrada más 4 y más algo es igual a
es igual a 4
ahora que tenemos aquí tomamos la mitad
del -2 que es menos 1 y al cuadrado se
vuelve 1 sumamos 1 no tenemos nada
afuera del paréntesis así que realmente
sólo sumamos 1 al miembro izquierdo de
la ecuación así que también debemos
sumar 1 al miembro derecho y ahora
tomamos la mitad de 4 que es 2 y al
cuadrado es 4 y ponemos un 4 aquí pero
también debemos sumarlo al miembro
derecho de la ecuación y de hecho
sumamos solo 4 porque no había nada
multiplicando al 4 ahí afuera
ahora esto se convierte en x menos 1 al
cuadrado más y más 2 al cuadrado es
igual a cuatro más uno más 4 es igual a
9 y aquí lo tenemos tenemos la ecuación
de la circunferencia en su forma más
simple
recuerda que si un círculo tiene el
centro en el origen su ecuación es la
forma más simple sería x cuadrada más y
cuadrada igual a ere cuadrada donde la
ere cuadrada es el radio al cuadrado y
esto nos dice que el radio de esta
circunferencia es 3 y ha sido desplazada
lo cual significa que su centro en lugar
de estar en el origen está en el punto 1
coma menos 2
y para saber la razón de estos valores
sólo hay que pensar qué valor hace esta
expresión igual a 0 en este caso era el
origen en este es x igual a 1 y el valor
que hace esta expresión igual a 0 en
este caso fue 0 y ahora es igual a menos
2 por lo tanto ese es el centro de la
circunferencia ese es el radio de la
circunferencia y ahora estamos listos
para graficar la
así que déjame ver demográfica la
circunferencia primero
mg
mg x con eso es suficiente y sólo quiero
graficar la circunferencia
entonces será el
y
en
aquí es el centro y el radio
el radio
estrés así que esta distancia es 3 en
cualquier dirección ésta mide 3 y esta
también mide 3
ese fue un ejercicio bastante sencillo
las circunferencias de alguna manera al
sol pero yo dije que trataríamos con una
elipse y seguro dirán esta no es una
elipse pero recuerda que si dividimos
ambos lados de la ecuación por 9
obtenemos
x menos 1 al cuadrado sobre 9 más y más
2 al cuadrado sobre 9 igual a 1 y ahí
vemos que el eje horizontal creo o el
diámetro horizontal mide 3 quise decir
el radio horizontal mide 3 y el radio
vertical igual mide 3 y como el radio
nunca cambia en esta elipse vemos que en
realidad es una circunferencia hagamos
uno más
esto es solo para asegurarnos de que
tienen estos conocimientos bien tengo
2x cuadrada más y más 12 x más
16 igual a
busquemos términos de x cuadrada y deje
cuadrada aquí hay un término de x
cuadrada pero no veo uno de g cuadrada
así que es un poco como un acertijo y
esto lo llevará a descubrir la cuarta de
nuestras cónicas de la cual hablé en el
primer vídeo pero en realidad no hemos
tratado todavía y esta es la parábola
pero como sé que es una parábola yo
ahondar en esto en futuros vídeos y en
todas las formas que puede tener una
parábola ya saben que los puntos son
equidistantes tanto a un punto como una
recta y todo eso pero en pocas palabras
ustedes reconocen a la parábola más
simple y es de la forma de igual a x
cuadrada la cual se ve más o menos así y
su punto mínimo o vértice está en el
origen o si tienen una parábola como x
igual a ye cuadrada se ve así la cual es
igual a la anterior pero volteada y otra
vez con el vértice en el origen
por ahora no veré eso pero mientras
tanto nosotros sabemos que es una
parábola porque tenemos una y una equis
cuadrada correcto tienen grados
diferentes no hay ningún término de g de
segundo grado y solo para poner esto de
una forma que les sea familiar restamos
todo menos la del miembro izquierdo de
la ecuación para tener igual a menos 2 x
cuadrada
- 12 x menos 16
y esta es más o menos la forma que les
es familiar
probablemente están acostumbrados a
encontrar los ceros de esta parábola lo
cual podemos hacer justo ahora podemos
decir está bien cuando esta ecuación
ínter seca al eje de las x el eje de las
x es cuando lay es igual a 0 entonces
igualando a 0 tenemos menos
2x cuadrada
- 12 x menos 16 y esto es diferente a lo
que siempre hacemos normalmente lo
primero que haría sería completar
cuadrados pero esta vez primero quiero
encontrar los ceros así que este 0 es
igual a menos 2 factor izando el menos 2
por equis cuadrada más 6 x más 8
entonces el cero es igual a menos 2 por
x + 2 por x + 4 factor izando de nuevo y
ahora para que todo esto sea 0 o esto es
igual a cero o esto lo es entonces o x +
20 o x + 4 es cero así que x es igual a
menos 2 y x es igual a menos 4 esos son
los dos ceros parábola
inmediatamente sabemos algo sobre esta
parábola y seguramente ya han hecho esto
en sus clases de álgebra si dibujamos el
eje x
está lo inter seca
en 1
-2 ahí y en 3
y menos 4 justo ahí
pero veamos si podemos usar nuestras
habilidades para completar cuadrados
para obtener más información sobre la
parábola tratemos de completar el
cuadrado lo voy a escribir de nuevo por
aquí abajo ya igual a esto es con lo que
estamos trabajando deja tomar los
términos de x por sí mismos y factorizar
el menos dos menos dos por equis
cuadrada más 6x más algo más y aparte
tenemos un -16 por aquí para hacer esto
un cuadrado perfecto debo tomar la mitad
de esto la mitad de 6 que es 3 y al
cuadrado es 9
si sumo 9 al miembro derecho de la
ecuación pero recuerden no sólo sume 9
esto es 9 x menos 2 así que si restó
menos 18 si restó 18 del miembro derecho
también debo hacerlo en el miembro
izquierdo así que restó 18 aquí
en la ecuación queda de menos 18 igual a
menos 2 por que hay aquí x más 3 al
cuadrado
-16 y pongámoslo en una forma que sea
fácil reconocer de nuestras cónicas
sumemos 16 de ambos lados de 18 + 16
queda de menos 2 le pondré paréntesis a
esto igual a menos 2 por x más 3 al
cuadrado y se pueden preguntar por qué
lo puse de esta forma y es porque esto
nos ayudará esto es más o menos como el
patrón que hemos visto en las otras
cónicas si yo les dijera que graficarán
por ejemplo que igual a x cuadrada
de igual a x cuadrada se vería como
déjenme dibujar
dibujamos unos ejes por aquí
je je
ye igual a equis cuadrada
se vería así es una parábola con el
vértice en el origen
y ahí es donde está el vértice en el
punto mínimo o en el punto máximo de la
parábola hablaremos más y aprenderán más
sobre esto cuando entremos a cálculo
pero creo que por ahora pueden
reconocerlo como el punto más bajo de la
uv o el más alto de la uv si quisiera
dibujar de igual
- x cuadrada ustedes podrían trazar
algunos puntos pero se vería algo así
y ahora quiero dibujar de igual a
2x cuadrada sería igual que llego a la
equis cuadrada pero crecería dos veces
más rápido sería así con el vértice en
el origen
y finalmente si quiero dibujar que igual
a menos 2 x
cuadrada sería así abriría hacia abajo y
de crecería dos veces más rápido
ahora está la ecuación con la que
terminamos aquí es lo mismo que llego al
menos 2 x cuadrada tiene la misma forma
general pero en lugar de tener el
vértice o su punto más alto como quieran
llamarlo en el origen está desplazado
ustedes pueden pensar que el valor de i
ac esta expresión igual a 0 pues es
igual a 2
mientras que en el otro caso el valor de
g que hace esta expresión igual a cero
es cero porque estábamos en el origen y
aquí qué valor de x hace esto cero pues
es x igual a menos 3
esto nos da información de dónde está el
vértice está en 2 está en x igual a
menos 3 y igualados
entonces está en x igual a
llegó a la
12 está justo ahí nosotros ya conocíamos
esos puntos porque buscamos los ceros de
la ecuación pero aún así si no los
conociéramos sabemos que tienen la forma
general de llego a la menos 12 x
cuadrada así que abra hacia abajo como
está y un poco más rápido que ya iguala
- x cuadrada así que se va a ver así
y sabemos que pasa por este punto y
también por este punto
y listo ya hemos visto todas las cónicas
y en los próximos dos vídeos profundizar
un poco más en la teoría detrás de las
cónicas pero creo que ya están listos
para atacar mucho de lo que puedan ver
en su examen de álgebra nos vemos pronto